okay your recompression real fast they
are coming for us we have to protect our
own the only thing standing between them
and awesome
alright guys Walking Dead Season seven
Comic Con trailer I don't know anybody
else was caught up with The Walking Dead
in my life that I could watch this with
we're gonna do this right now I know the
big thing is who did negan kill it's
very obvious he killed Rick Rick's dead
people if you look at all the possible
theories and the origins of the comics
it's obviously Rick Kidd it's clearly
Maggie
Hey
since you're in the club math you have
to wear the hat I've got short as hair
was it yeah
with you
Tim who assemble this trailer Dolph
watch footage
we fight we do it together God
please sit
or will be we should have made it deal
with them when we could you should know
there is no door number four this is the
only way
ouch
I am King Ezekiel welcome to the kingdom
damn Sam gets tired a lot during the
apocalypse go boys one knock someone out
with the butt of a shotgun Wow
people people people people that was
like a trailer for all different [ __ ]
it's smart because all the people that
were in the circle we didn't see them
travelling around and [ __ ] he was
showing us a whole new set of characters
we got a zekiel in there who looks like
my great-grandfather they showed like
miniature clips of negan when he's like
dashing whoever he's [ __ ] bashing I
know in the comics it was Glenn I really
hope they don't hold back on that moment
I'm hoping it's Maggie cuz I think she's
pregnant if I recall I would love to see
that pregnant [ __ ] get smashed I'm
kidding I'm kidding
Carl everyone wants Carl that we can all
agree on that I really hope it's not
like Aaron or Eugene oh basalt Abraham
we need it to be like a major character
we need this to be a major [ __ ]
character
you can't half-ass it on someone who's
like likable but not one of the faves
The Walking Dead it has really
interesting unique storytelling
capabilities I wouldn't be surprised
because they oh they always do like you
know season seven first half season
seven second half and I feel like the
first half I honestly wouldn't be
surprised if they didn't tell us who
needing killed with Rick and his group
until like of the second half of season
seven it's clearly introducing a bunch
of new characters the kingdom is a new
place that will probably fall down
eventually either by other survivors or
by walkers taken over you know like
let's just face it humans are gonna die
humans or don't stand a chance in this
war they should all just kill themselves
if an apocalypse happened in real life
Gunn too
brain is what I would do to myself that
or a toaster while I'm shower okay no I
was going to commit suicide I would have
you know chains to my wrists chains to
my feet
chains tied up to one part of a car feet
other part of the car car strength how
many people self to commit suicide cars
drive separately Shh body splits it's
fine doesn't wanna be like yes job yes
sir
which negan was real take care of some
annoying people in my home right now I
mean the promotion was really
interesting because you know we're
season seven we're thinking about that
last moment of season six it's like well
nothing is really going off of that last
moment of season six because this is
like a just a whole new chapter here
that stuff with Carol or if she looked
like she was having like a great time
that was [ __ ] weird
Kendall never looks like she's having a
great time I don't want to see Carol
have a great time
I don't like Carol happy I don't like
her smiling she smiles again bullet to
the head but I really want to see is
that Tiger murdering a bunch of zombies
though if that Tiger can get really
involved in the action no if I were to
commit suicide Tiger season six really
spent a long time building omnium season
seven I really hope the writing
delivered I'm sure they will the actor
Jeffrey Dean Morgan fantastic actor best
part of BVS for sure I really hope negan
can provoke the psychotic nests at of
rick rick has clearly gone down some
psychopathic territory I love it one of
my favorite aspects of the show if these
two can become Psychopaths just trying
to kill each other while having to deal
with walkers I think we got a good show
AMC 7c isn't in might be your good luck
charm for near this channel subscribe to
the real rejects yay hoorah hoorah
follow me on Facebook Instagram Twitter
hoorah I gotta go